[Laughter]
[Music]
yes I saw you guys waving me over
my name is orgy short for again
now what about mean is born oh we just
wanted to order god no no no totally
let's make all the old tress over gonna
get the dull stuff out of the way before
we can just start shelling you know just
good smoking inside you know what are
not just they are pretty incredible
we'll get a picture and some nachos good
job Larry ring ring ring ring ringing
alarm you know I'll go but then and I'll
be right back you're in bed wanna check
come on my table pals put your order in
so we can hang a drink you guys know
that one could we get some cups what are
you guys doing tonight are you going to
a bass beat game because you're so
obsessed with pictures I would be fun to
hang out with you you know I just
started as iterator but we bonded and we
chose I can tell they're something
special I would save you as your child
because that's what friends are for
when you think those nachos will be
ready yeah we don't serve that we don't
serve nachos I lied to impress you guys
if you need anything just scream at me